[Music]
in this video you can look forward to
the most exciting animated films of the
coming months from the Super Mario
Brothers movie to the announced the Lord
of the Rings animation film all the big
names are included what we can already
reveal is that the upcoming movie
schedule is looking pretty promising for
fans of animation movies so get ready
and enjoy our new preview
the Super Mario Brothers movie from
Universal awaits us at the beginning of
April since the release of the first
trailer in October 2022 the film has
been talked about by everyone it is
based on the world famous video game
franchise which has inspired many
generations now a lovingly animated
feature film from the creators of the
minions is waiting for the fans even
though there are a few differences of
opinion regarding the dubbing as many
would have preferred the voice actor
from the games Charles martinet whether
Jurassic world star Chris Pratt delivers
an equally convincing performance is
something fans can check out in theaters
starting April 7th 2023.
a long-weighted animated Adventure will
finally be released in the summer of
2023. we're talking about Spider-Man
across the spider-verse which will bring
the popular main character Miles Morales
back to the big screen in inimitable
fashion we already got to meet some
intriguing versions of the friendly
neighborhood spider in the first movie
from 2018 and that's exactly the
experience they're hoping to repeat in
the sequels in order to achieve this the
number of characters in the film has
been increased to 240 and we are given
the opportunity to experience a total of
six elaborately designed animation
Styles depending on the story the entire
world is supposed to change and thus set
a new standard in animation miles and
his girlfriend Gwen Stacy AKA spider
Gwen are to be the main focus but other
characters such as Spider-Man 2099 and
spider Punk will also appear in the
course of the story to shorten the
waiting time until the theatrical
release on June 2nd 2023. we suggest you
watch the trailer which was released at
the end of 2022 and provides some
insights into the sequel by the way this
film will get another sequel less than a
year later titled spider man beyond the
spider-verse which will possibly
conclude The Saga of Miles Morales
Pixar is also included in our list this
year with a new movie the film Elemental
is scheduled to hit the big screen on
June 16 2023 and tells the story of an
unequal Duo namely water and fire in the
film The two elements are embodied by
two characters who live in a city
composed of all four elements so each
inhabitant represents either water fire
air or Earth in the end the characters
are supposed to find out how much these
counterparts who at first glance seem
unequal have in common with each other
there's already a concept image of the
two main figures as well as a first
trailer which definitely looks promising
so we are definitely excited
with Leonardo Donatello Raphael and
Michelangelo the four most famous
turtles in the world are also making
their grand return in 2023. this not
only pleases Children of the 1980s as
the younger generation has also long
since found access to numerous comics in
series after 2016's Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Out of the Shadows the need for
a refreshing remake is more pressing
than ever which is partly due to the
movie's mediocre reviews skeptical fans
can at least be sure of one thing though
with Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg two
self-proclaimed Fanatics of the
franchise are responsible for the
production which is why a poor movie
adaptation is rather impossible fans are
much more critical of another Ninja
Turtle spin-off and live-action format
however which has been produced by
Paramount for several years but hasn't
had an update in a while whether Seth
Rogen's animated film teenage mutant
ninja turtles mutant Mayhem will be able
to meet the high expectations of the fan
Community will be revealed with its
release on August 11 2023.
Disney's wish is to come out at the end
of the year in the style of a musical
the story is about a Wishing Star which
is discovered by the 17 year old main
character Asha she is a princess of
roses the kingdom of wishes where she
and her family have lived for a long
time roses is a place where all
imaginable wishes come true in a moment
of Crisis Asher herself makes a wish to
the stars and in order to solve her
problem she receives what at First Sight
seems to be an unusual gift but Stellar
together they must face a great
Challenge in a musical format that is
particularly suitable for animated films
so far there are many positive opinions
about the film some even feel a little
reminiscent of Encanto which also
managed to implement an original plot in
a very convincing way however the style
of wish will be a little different the
focus is on a Timeless watercolor style
combined with contemporary 3D animation
as it says in the official Disney
website we are definitely excited and
look forward to the theatrical release
on November 22nd 2023
right before Christmas animation fans
can see Universal's migration in
theaters the film by Ernest and
Celestine director Benjamin Renner
revolves around a duck family that sets
off on an unusual journey together the
kids as well as the mother try to
convince the male head of the family to
take the vacation of a lifetime The
Adventurous trip eventually leads the
little family via New York City to the
Bahamas along the way not only many
wonderful moments await but also plenty
of dangers unfortunately there is still
no trailer available to take a closer
look at the project however there is
still some time left until the movie's
release on December 22nd
23 years have already passed since the
release of the animation classic chicken
run the animated stop-motion film is
undoubtedly one of the best known and
most popular of its kind which is why
many fans now have high expectations for
the sequel the new adventure of Rocky
Ginger Molly and the others is being
produced by Netflix this time and will
therefore be released exclusively in the
streaming service the production time
can certainly be considered as long
since the first announcement for Chicken
Run 2 was already made back in 2018 but
it should also be taken into account
that the stop-motion process is very
complex and requires a practice workflow
according to the official synopsis
Chicken Run dawn of the Nugget will tell
the events after the successful escape
attempt at the hen ginger on film Ginger
and her friends settle on a deserted
island but soon have to fight together
against a threat from the mainland
currently November 10th is being
reported to be the release date for
chicken run dawn of the Nugget however
there hasn't been an update regarding
the release for quite some time
the releases will continue in 2024 with
Kung Fu Panda 4. the well-known
DreamWorks film series which made its
debut in 2008 last achieved a fair
amount of success with Kung Fu Panda 3
and has since been waiting for a fourth
part for seven years the story will once
again revolve around the greedy Panda
Poe who was originally voiced by comedy
icon Jack Black and whose greatest hobby
is the martial art of kung fu
financially the film series has been
profitable for DreamWorks so far overall
the movies have grossed close to 1.8
billion US Dollars however not only the
movies were successful in the meantime
there was a whole franchise consisting
of a TV series and various video games
for example no details are known yet
about the plot of the fourth movie
however many speculate that Poe may
start his own family in the upcoming
part either way the action comedy will
certainly provide humorous moments for
the whole family again and DreamWorks
will do its best to live up to the name
of the movie series Kung Fu Panda 4 will
be released in cinemas on March 8th
2024.
in addition to the current the Lord of
the Rings series from streaming giant
Amazon an animated film based on the
world famous fantasy Saga is also in the
works the Lord of the Rings The War of
the rohiram a first look has already
been provided by variety which
exclusively published two concept images
at the beginning of 2022. in addition to
the breathtaking nature and many
warriors you can also see a Muma kill
one of the powerful elephant creatures
that we saw in action in The Lord of the
Rings The Return of the King however the
visuals are by no means relevant for the
later film as for the first time in the
history of the film series the plot will
be told in the form of an anime the
story on the other hand is only remotely
related to Peter Jackson's film series
taking place 250 years before the latter
and dealing with the story of Helm
hammerhand production is currently
running at full speed with a theatrical
release date set for April 12 2024.
in early summer a new Garfield movie
will be produced by Sony pictures in
terms of story content those responsible
are relying on the comic book series
which published its first volume in 1978
and has been expanded by numerous films
and Series in the meantime as in the
Super Mario Brothers movie Chris Pratt
will also play the main character here
slipping into the role of the Moody and
cynical cat in addition fans can look
forward to Samuel L Jackson as
Garfield's father and Nicholas Holt as
John Arbuckle the cat's owner in
contrast to the two films with Bill
Murray released in the 2000s the film
will rely entirely on animation and will
not include any live-action Elements
which has so far been met with mostly
positive reactions there is no
information about the plot so far but
there is still some time left until the
plan release date on May 24 2024 anyway
inside out from 2015 is undoubtedly a
modern animation classic the Oscar
winner was able to convince both film
critics and fans around the world the
anticipation was correspondingly great
when there was an official talk of a
sequel in 2022 to be released in 2024
the story of the original was to be
continued but there will be a small time
jump to the difficult teenage years of
the main character Riley emotions of Joy
disgust sorrow and so on which are
portrayed by film characters will of
course also be part of the story again
and play a crucial role actress Amy
Poehler who already dubbed joy in 2015
already spoke out about the sequel she
teased that Riley's emotional
intelligence has changed greatly which
makes perfect sense after all the
emotional world of a teenager is
sometimes very different from that of a
child the script is said to have been
completed since the end of last year by
the way it is written by Meg Lafave once
again this time Pete doctor is not in
charge of directing instead it's Kelsey
Mann the latter wrote the screenplay for
the good dinosaur which was also
released in 2015. Inside Out 2 is
scheduled to hit theaters on June 14
and that was our new original for this
week in order to stay up to date on the
best animated films of the coming years
we recommend to keep up with our weekly
news which of the movies mentioned are
among your favorites and which project
could be a real surprise hit feel free
to leave your opinion in the comments
down below
[Music]
thank you